F
THE MOST PRIVILEGE.
NOW, HERE TO DISCUSS KAYLEIGH
McENANY, CO-HOST OF OUTMUSH
NUMBERED AND FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY, OF COURSE AND
KARL ROVE, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
YOU KNOW, BOTH OF YOU HAVE
EXTRAORDINARY ACCESS.
YOU BOTH HAVE BEEN IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
HAVE YOU BOTH BEEN ADVISING AND
WORKING WITH THE TOP TIER OF
POWER, THE PRESIDENTS OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE, I
THINK, THAT THIS IS GIGANTIC
SYSTEM.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE, CAILEE, LET
ME ASK YOU, DO YOU THINK I'M
GOING TOO FAR IN MY ASSESSMENT
HERE?
IT SEEMS LIKE THE AVERAGE PERSON
HAS GOTTEN LOST IN A MACHINE NOW
THAT JUST DOESN'T CARE.
>> I THINK YOU ARE SPOT ON.
LOOK, PRESIDENT OBAMA RECENTLY
SAID THAT PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN IS
FINISHING WHAT I STARTED BUT
LET'S NOT FORGET WHAT PRESIDENT
OBAMA STARTED ENDED IN THE
PRESIDENCY OF PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT EXIT
POLLING THROUGH THE PRIMARIES,
ONE POLL ALWAYS STUCK OUT TO ME
AND THIS WAS THE 2016 PRIMARY.
AND IT WAS THIS THEY FELT
BETRAYED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THAT WAS AT A RECORD HIGH AND
BLUE STATES, IN FACT, THE
BETRAYAL OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT METRIC WAS CLOSE TO
50% IN SOME BLUE STATES.
AND THAT EXISTED FOR A VERY
SPECIFIC REASON.
AMERICANS WERE LEFT BEHIND AND
BY CONTRAST WHEN YOU GOT TO
2019, PRE-PANDEMIC, AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP, YOU SAW THE
LARGEST ANNUAL GAINS OF MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD INCOME ON RECORD.
GROUPS THAT HAVE BEEN
TRADITIONALLY LEFT BEHIND,
PLAQUE AMERICANS, HISPANIC
AMERICANS DISPROPORTIONATELY SAW
THOSE FANS.
POVERTY AT A LOW GOING BACK TO
1959.
THE RESULTS WERE THERE.
I THINK DOUBLING DOWN ON THE
OBAMA POLICIES IS A REAL RISK
FOR PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN EVEN IF
HE DOESN'T SEE IT NOW.
>> Tammy: IT'S FASCINATING.
KARL.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THE SHOCKING POSITION OF DONALD
TRUMP THAT WE WERE TOLD COULD
NEVER HAPPEN THAT THIS IS JUST,
YOU KNOW, NEW NORMALS AND JUST A
GLOBAL THING AND THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS.
SUDDENLY THERE IS PROOF THAT,
WAIT A MINUTE, ONE PERSON CAN
MAKE THE DIFFERENCE.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE NATURE
OF WHAT IS HAPPENING, AND I KNOW
NUMBERS ARE YOUR THING AND THE
FACTS OF THE MATTER WITH WHAT
GOES BACK TO LEGISLATION AND
EVERYTHING ELSE, BUT THIS IS A
REAL PERSONAL REACTION BY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN GOVERNMENT RIGHT
NOW.
>> YEAH.
I THINK IT IS VERY PERSONAL IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE THEY WERE
MISLEAD.
THERE WAS NO MANDATE CREATED FOR
THIS BY A CAMPAIGN IN 2020 THAT
SAID ELECT JOE BIDEN PRESIDENT
HE IS GOING TO ASK FOR
$6 TRILLION TO BE ADDED TO THE
DEFICIT.
IS HE GOING TO CALL FOR A HUGE
EXPANSION OF FEDERAL POWER AND
THE GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO TAKE
OVER EVERYTHING FROM RUNNING
YOUR ELECTIONS TO DETERMINING
WHAT KIND OF CAR YOU DRIVE TO
WHAT YOUR KIDS LEARN IN SCHOOL
AND SO FORTH.
NONE OF THAT WAS DONE DURING THE
CAMPAIGN.
VERY SIMPLE MESSAGE DURING THE
JOE BIDEN IS NOT DONALD TRUMP
AND DONALD TRUMP IS SCREWING UP
COVID.
SO, PART OF THE REACTION THAT I
THINK IS STARTING AND WE'RE
GOING TO SEE MORE OF IT IS AS
ORDINARY AMERICANS SAY WAIT A
MINUTE, YOU DIDN'T TELL ME ABOUT
THIS.
AND THE SMUGNESS OF THE ELITES
ACADEMIA, UNIONS, MEDIA, PART OF
BIG BUSINESS AND IN THE
GOVERNMENT, IN THE THINK TANKS,
THIS IS GOING TO GROW THE AN NOT
CITY OF THE ORDINARY PEOPLE IS
GOING TO GROW.
>> Tammy: WE HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF
HOW FAR THE AVERAGE PEOPLE ARE
REACTING.
BOTH OF YOU LISTEN.
BUT KAYLEIGH I WANT TO GET YOUR
REACTION ON THAT.
CALLING OUT BRIAN STELTER.
>> I'M GOING TO ASK BRIAN TO, ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION, ADMIT HE
AND HIS NETWORK ARE A BUNCH OF
LIARS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
KEVIN, IN PRINCETON, INDIANA,
GOOD MORNING.
>> MR. STELTZER IS THE BIGGEST
MINISTER OF MISINFORMATION I
HAVE EVER HEARD AND I'M A NEWS
JUNKY.
HE MADE THE STATEMENT JUST A FEW
MINUTES AGO THAT HE IS -- THE
STORIES ARE ALWAYS EVOLVING.
YEAH, HIS STORIES, ABSOLUTELY
EVOLVED.
>> BRIAN SELTZER.
>> THANK YOU FOR THE FEEDBACK.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> SAVANNAH, GEORGIA, RICK, GOOD
MORNING.
YOU ARE NEXT.
>> YES.
I WAS JUST WONDERING IF YOU
STILL FEEL LIKE MICHAEL AVENATTI
IS THE GREATEST THING IN THE
WORLD AND SHOULD RUN FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES?
MY SUGGESTION IS WHATEVER CNN
SAYS, DO THE OPPOSITE AND YOU
WILL BE FINE.
>> AURORA, INDIANA, THIS IS
ROBERT.
GOOD MORNING, YOU ARE ON WITH
BRIAN STELTER.
>> YOU KNOW, CNN IS JUST
SOMETHING THAT'S A JOKE.
IT'S A JOKE.
THIS GUY TELLS MORE LIES AND FOX
GIVES MORE NEWS THAN CNN DOES.
>> WHAT LIE DID I TELL?
>> NOTHING BUT LIES.
>> Tammy: WOW, THERE IT IS, WHEN
YOU DON'T SCREEN THE CALLS,
REGULAR AMERICANS CALL.
IN KAYLEIGH, WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON
THAT?
>> THAT WHAT A SECURING.
NO WONDER HIS RATES ARE DOWN 53%
SINCE JANUARY.
THAT'S A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THE
MEDIA ELITE THAT KARL JUST
MENTIONED.
HE SAYS WHAT LIES?
LIES, MISTRUTHS WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL IT ONE EXAMPLE IS
THE IG REPORT THAT SHOWS
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOT CLEAR
THE PATH IN LAFAYETTE PARK WITH
TEAR GAS.
CLEAR THE PATH OF PROTESTERS IN
ORDER TO HAVE A PHOTO OP.
CONTRARY TO WHAT JIM ACOSTA
SUGGESTED TIME AND TIME AGAIN ON
THAT NETWORK.
WE KNOW THE RUSSIA BOUNTY STORY.
RUSSIA BANK ACCOUNTS WERES ON
THE HEADS OF AMERICAN SOLDIERS,
THAT WAS NOT THE CASE.
THEY SAID PRESIDENT TRUMP
IGNORED THAT WE KNOW WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS CALLED CRAZY
FOR SAYING THE WUHAN LAB MIGHT
BE THE ORIGIN FOR COVID-19.
IN FACT, IT LOOKS LIKE HE MIGHT
HAVE BEEN RIGHT AFTER ALL.
THAT'S JUST THREE EXAMPLES OF
MANY.
NO WONDER THAT NOW 79% OF
INDEPENDENTS SAY THAT THEY
BELIEVE THE MEDIA MAKES UP FAKE
STORIES AND INTENTIONALLY
PLUSHES THEM.
THAT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY
STATISTIC.
>> Tammy: KARL, WE HAVE A FEW
SECONDS HERE.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON HIM FINALLY
HEARING THE REALITY OF WHAT
PEOPLE THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE
DOING OVER THERE?
>> I SUSPECT THAT THE MOMENT HE
WAS THINKING TO HIMSELF WHAT THE
HECK AM I DOING HERE?
[LAUGHTER]
BUT IT'S A LESSON OF WHAT
UNFILTERED TELEVISION WILL GIVE
YOU.
GIVES A SENSE THE ORDINARY
AMERICANS HAVE A LOT OF COMMON
SENSE.
>> Tammy: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> THEY ARE THE PEOPLE PAYING
THE BILL AT THE GROCERY STORE
AND SEEING PRICES GOING UP.
THEY'RE THE PEOPLE WORRYING
ABOUT WHAT DEBT IS GOING TO DO
TO THEIR KIDS.
THERIOT PEOPLE THAT SAY WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT TRANSFORMATION OF OUR
COUNTRY, I LIKE OUR COUNTRY THE
WAY IT IS.
WHEN PEOPLE START TALKING ABOUT
WOKENESS, IT STARTS TO GET --
THEY SAY I'M ALREADY AWAKE.
>> Tammy: LOOK, THE DEMOCRATS
ARE SEEING THAT RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THEY ARE APPROPRIATELY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THE FUTURE
LOOKS LIKE FOR THAT PARTY.
THANK YOU BOTH VERY M